on montre qu'on peut faire du seul
différemment qu'il faut faire du cirque
différemment qu'il faut aller de l'avant
le cirque ne va pas mourir parce qu'on
ne présente plus d'animaux sur la piste
[Musique]
tous
nous étions profondément contre la
chasse la pêche à faire toutes ses
formes d'exploitation animal et
nous-mêmes étions docteur donc on a une
vraie réflexion par rapport à ça on a eu
envie une fois que nos animaux on
commence à vieillir à décéder et c'est
de changer de voie et surtout d'en mener
notre métier dans un nouvel air nous ne
voulions pas transmettre de fausses
traditions à nos enfants
par rapport à notre profession nous
sommes avant tout des artistes des
saltimbanques des entrepreneurs de
spectacles et notre métier c'est de
faire rêver et de divertir le plus grand
public et l'équation des animaux pose
vraiment problème la nouvelle génération
pose problème à la planète pose
énormément de problèmes éthiques et on a
décidé la d'avoir des écrans et des
hologrammes qui vont représenter des
univers différents magique et surtout
des animaux donc pas des animaux
emblématiques du monde du cirque
mi-décembre animaux emblématiques de la
déforestation du réchauffement
climatique donc des ours et animaux
marins
les animaux d'afrique etc je veux pas
cueilli sa voix parce que ça se voit
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment très très
moche c'est ce qu'on appelle un tulle
holographique ces sources
sur ce support là que les hologrammes
sont projetés la particularité de ça
c'est que selon l'éclairage donc là on
voit bien selon l'éclairage il est
complètement transparente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes des ovnis et nous avons été
largement maltraités à ce sujet ça a été
très mal perçue mais tant mieux ça nous
a donné des ailes pour pour continuer et
pour pour monter tout ça tant qu'ancien
docteur on est actif dans la protection
animale de par des actions qu'on mène
avec notre éco cirque et donc on est
quelque part dans une continuité de
travail avec les animaux mais tout
simplement différemment
comment
ouais
bon
il réfléchit à pouvoir faire un nouveau
numéro sans les animaux
donc ça a été une année difficile quand
moi forcément ce que j'ai vécu dix ans
auprès des animaux j'ai dû renouveler
quand j'ai commencé le ser tôt je me
suis dit ah c'est un objet ça va être
difficile d'établir un lien donc après
la reconversion et ebit c'est parce que
je me suis pris de passion pour l'aérien
finalement
[Musique]
mon rôle au sein de l'ecosoc brouillonne
et d'intégrer des contenus vidéos
dynamiques dans la narration du
spectacle je ne m'imaginais pas que le
cirque traditionnel connaîtrait cette
mutation aussi rapidement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Musique]
on
comment
oh
[Musique]